he's David Carr NFL Network analyst and
you can see him tonight NFL Total Access
at six Eastern Thursday Night Football
continues this week Jets Browns
exclusively on NFL Network David good
morning thanks for joining us how would
you assess your brothers performance
yesterday against Denver well try to be
unbiased
but I sat there and watched the game and
he looked really good you know it took
some shots down the field that's the
first time I've seen Amari Cooper with
you know ten targets catch ten footballs
I mean for the most part on offense you
know they move the ball effectively
maybe would have liked to come away with
a couple more points you know going down
there in the red zone but end of the day
you got to get some stops on defense and
find a way to win that thing I mean
that's that's a tough place to play you
go to Denver altitude it's high you can
see the pastor sit in the game a lot
it's gonna be made of that with you know
Khalil Mack not being out there and
that's that's a real thing but at some
point we got to get over it and and find
a way to get to the quarterback at me
Arden he was gassed and it just looks
like we could have used some maybe a
rotation or two and therefore those guys
because that that last drive was a
non-existent pass rush and they had to
create it the entire game with you know
some Apollo Gunter's you know schemes
and blitz packages which was effective
but the end of the game you got to cover
guys you got to make plays and you gotta
find a way to get to the quarterback and
they weren't able to do it what's harder
to explain Ryan Fitzpatrick or Patrick
mahomes you know what I think that
really at the end of it and I was kind
of sitting there watching that game with
you know what Ryan Fitzpatrick was able
to do you know quarterbacks at where
he's at I mean I played against the guy
in his first time he was on the field
I'm in Bruce 2019 2004 or 2005 in
Houston we were up 21 nothing in the
first half
we're cruising to victory which was rare
for us and comes in and just lights it
up touchdown this guy from the Ivy
League so I think at some point you know
you get to a point if you're able to
stick around long enough physically and
stay healthy you know mentally he's seen
so much I mean that was well today two
decades ago you know so he's seen so
much from a
from a blood standpoint from a defensive
perspective if you're able to keep your
body physically you know capable you can
do things like that in old days and
that's why Tom Brady's still able to
kick around Drew Brees I mean there's
nothing these guys haven't seen so I'm
not surprised but Patrick mahomes the
first time I saw Patrick you know
watched a little bit on film went out to
the combine a couple years ago saw him
throw the ball in person and I was just
kind of an odd how how strong his arm
was and then the different angles he was
able to you know utilize his release
point and he just the arm talent-wise I
hadn't seen anything really like it and
you know when Andy Reed made the move to
ship out Alex Smith who he said was
pretty much perfect for his system it
kind of just told you man Andy wouldn't
make this movie he didn't think he had
something special with this kid Patrick
so and we've kind of seen it the first
couple weeks the guy has got infectious
energy I mean he's just a he just loves
playing football you know and there's
you know Andy Reed coached a guy like
that back in Green Bay you know a few
decades ago so if there was any way they
could kind of rein him in and get him to
not make some of the kind of crazy not
bonehead plays but plays that you make
when you just have that kind of ability
or if you try to bake when you have that
kind of ability they've been able to do
that and you know you can hear him even
when he talks is I'm just trying to get
the ball to my playmakers and get the
ball in their hands and that that's just
great coaching you know from from Andy
and his staff and to be able to kind of
get Patrick to you know already look
like a top-ten quarterback is pretty
fantastic well I also give Andy Reed
credit and I don't do that very often
but I give him credit because he
realized that Alex Smith was perfect for
his system but the problem is that
system could only take you so far he
needed somebody who could stretch the
field and make that defense nervous and
mahomes makes that defense nervous Andy
makes Kelsey and Hill even more
dangerous and that's why I think this is
real with Kansas City because I don't
know how the good the defense is but it
might not have to be that good because
that offense is really good they just
have so many they create so many
problems for you from a defensive
perspective you have to you mean even
when you're paying attention to our
Tyreke Hill is you still have to be on
your horse and a full backpedal sprint
turn your hips and get out of there and
then and
just opened up everything else but you
know with with Travis Kelce now making a
couple plays you know he was kind of
absent the first week but we all knew
that was kind of just it was one of
those days it wasn't going to be
something that was continual them get a
couple jobs the opportunistic get some
turnovers they don't have to be great
clearly you know because Patrick
stretched in the field like this and you
know we haven't even really suited his
ability to create we haven't really seen
him outside the X's and O's yet and I
think that's one of his strengths so you
know we've just seen the arm talent on
display you know getting it to the
weapons that he has but as soon as he
starts chucking it running and moving
around I mean that's that's another
weapon that yet you know come out of
college so I think Andy's gonna love
he's David Carr NFL Network analyst you
can see him tonight NFL Total Access at
6:00 p.m. Eastern
what are you what were your
relationships like with kickers on your
team what could you be referencing were
great I Chris Brown's great in Houston
what I've heard is Jack now I mean the
guys at mr. Olympia I mean I like I like
kickers you know if for the most part
they just got to do their job and kind
of stay out of the way you know let's
let the real football players do their
thing they have the luxury of not ever
having to really be in the mix you know
so they can they can say things and do
things that are kind of outside the
grand scheme of what's going on but yeah
are they are they real football players
Tim I get that question a lot and I you
know I it's just really hard because
they never go to practice they're never
there they're never in your meetings you
know you walk down the hallway after
you've been in meetings for four hours
about to go to practice and they're in
there either eating frosted flakes or
you know doing some ABS and like you
know on the treadmill you're like what
are these guys part of our team are they
equipment managers like what's happening
here then you see them and then
obviously kickers are pretty important
because you see him yesterday I mean my
goodness somebody guys there's gonna be
some tryouts for some kickers I think
today if I had to guess around the
league that was that wasn't very good
how about we did incentive-based
contracts for kickers that if I gave you
money per kick what do you think about
that I think just cash a spur make you
know like here it is and now the head
coach's hand them whatever it is that
greets one and then maybe we have two or
three guides and we can just kind of
look and see looking their eyes on the
sideline and say yeah I think you got it
yeah you're gonna make this one send him
out there you know because I mean that's
at the end of the day it's so important
that's what's so crazy is it's so
important at the end of games I mean we
look at Mason Crosby this was kind of
wild me you didn't lose the game they
tied but he made five kicks you know but
only one you know even they even made
the one that they called the timeout on
you know they misses the last 52 yard
field goal so he can you know it sucks
but it's one of those deals I wouldn't
want to be one my children are not gonna
be raised to be kickers I'll say that
much are you sold on the Jags absolutely
if Blake bortles is gonna play the way
he played yesterday Jacksonville even
though we knew they were gonna be a
problem they're a real issue
for the rest of the AFC and and the
entire league for that matter because
you look at it even and the confidence
that the coaching staff Doug Marrone
showing him Blake you know they're
throwing the football with three minutes
left a minute left in the game
I mean they're on they're on the attack
mode and if teams were just going to
come in and bail a check yep I mean he's
a great coach but if they're gonna come
in and they're just gonna play man
coverage and stop the run which what you
have to do and and and Blake's just
gonna go out there and throw the ball
the way he did like that I don't know
how you beat him because the defense is
just suffocating you watch Tom and he's
doing everything he can from matchup
standpoint trying to get the ball to
Gronk but they're double-teaming him you
know three or four different ways and
trying to get other guys involved but
that pass rush is relentless the
linebackers are so fast it's gonna be
it's gonna be very difficult for teams
to find a way to crack this code because
I mean doing one doing one's as good as
anybody that it kind of shutting that
kind of stuff down and find ways to get
you guys the football but they say they
had no answers yesterday would you trade
for Josh Gordon if I was the Dallas
Cowboys yes absolutely
I thought what they showed you know what
Dallas Cowboys showed yesterday with
getting back involved in Zeke involved
in the in the zone reads and creating
some some runs for him I thought was
brilliant you know and people will say
oh well he can't sustain that Cam
Newton's really I don't care I don't
care if dak Prescott can only do that
for four or five years that's what he
does and that's the only way you're
gonna be successful with how your team
is built so stop trying to make him Tony
Romo he's not utilized his ability give
him a weapon outside that can take some
people out of the box and so they can do
more of that stuff into the run game is
even more effective
Josh Gordon has has had some issues he's
got some demons you've got some things
he's got to work through but I think
that the guy loves football and I I see
the talent when he's out there and Jerry
Jones taking shots on guys that have
done a lot worse than this so yeah I
would hope that Jerry would be one of
the guys that is on the phone trying to
make something happen today do you think
dak Prescott some franchise quarterback
I think dak Prescott is the Cowboys
franchise quarterback I think you know
you don't have to do too much you know I
know people are gonna sailing through
for a hundred and some yards yeah that's
all is necessary you know and if they
can just utilize him the way they did
yesterday they're gonna be fine because
I think their defense is gonna be good
enough to stop some people and make some
plays and I think their pass rush is
gonna is gonna hold up and Sean leak and
stay healthy he'll be fine
dak has a long way to go you know from
he's still missing guys wide open in the
end zone four touchdowns he misses
throws that you just shouldn't miss but
you know at the end of the day he has
other abilities and he showed those
yesterday
so if Scott Linehan were smart Jason
Garrett they're smart and they are just
go with that stick with that utilize him
in the run game
it's a weapon he's part of the run game
and it helps seek you know so do that
and if he grows as a passer great you
know if he doesn't then you know where
your bread sputtered man just stick with
it
good to catch up with you as always and
thanks for joining us you got a bet it's
David Carr NFL Network analyst former
NFL quarterback he's usually the poster
child when I tell you how talented
somebody is and I thought he was
extremely talented but you come out of
Fresno State but you get in a bad
situation where I think he was sacked an
average of 60 times there through his
first three seasons unheard of numbers
and he never had confidence back there
and it's so hard to get it back that
that's really the key it's hard to get
it back and that's where I see these
young quarterbacks and if you get thrown
in what are you getting thrown into and
is there a lifeline to take you out of
that or help you with that
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]